and so she told she caught my client to
do the same thing fast for over 20 years
my client is a comedy writer what does
that tell you
I think this is another blog post of
yours but I wanted to expand on it sure
so writers are great at explaining in
someone else's story but what about
their own especially when it comes to
presenting themselves to the world to
the studio system
what is that refining of their own story
what is too much how truthful do they be
you want a writer to be truthful when
they talk about themselves but you have
to also remember that a writer's first
story is their own so if they don't know
how to tell their story it's gonna be
tough to trust them with other stories
so you really have to figure out where
is the juice in your story it's never in
chronology or very rarely in chronology
if you travel to space sure chronology
is just fine but it is about finding a
way to connect your human experience for
lack of better words to the person who's
sitting across range to become
interesting to becoming unique to tell
them a story they haven't heard that is
truthful in yours and it can be
completely anecdotal you know I've
certainly talked to people who start out
saying I have I've never done anything
interesting in my life well then what's
your point of view on the things that
you've done what have you made of your
experiences to find those stories that
really speak to who you are as a person
and a writer to tell something
interesting and unique so that a month
later a month after general with an
executive Fiat and a production company
or a studio that executive looks at a
piece of work and says hey what happened
to the writer who the writer who had
that experience I can bring into this
one you know so it is about sharing
those experiences those points of view
and finding a way to tell that personal
story that is meaningful and that is
connective and that isn't tied up in a
bow doesn't have to be pretty it has to
be memorable and eloquent you have to be
comfortable talking about it so I can't
turn into a therapy session you know but
it has to be that story that nobody else
has to tell so you know for a while
everybody was talking about writers who
would go into networks and talk about
how television was their only friend
we've heard a lot of those stories so
those stories are no longer unique every
writer every person has an experience
has a point of view
that is uniquely theirs you don't have
to take half an hour to tell it in fact
we want to told in two minutes and three
minutes the most but relate to us
something that we can remember that
could speaks to who you are because
that's who we want to work with you know
I have a writer who is super talented
lovely lovely woman very very shy who
came to me and said I don't know what my
personal story is and I can't really
talk about it and so I had to bring in a
lot of anecdotes there are a lot of
different stories and they all came out
kind of sad and the problem was that
she's a comedy writer till one day she
brought me a story about her mother
she's Korean she grew up naturally with
a Korean mother who was obsessed with
not wrinkling her face so she taught
herself how to laugh without moving any
of the muscles on her face so that she
would never age and so she told she
taught my client to do the same thing
fast for over 20 years my client is a
comedy writer what does that tell you
of course she told it with a little bit
more flair in detail but those are the
kind of stories that stick that are
unique that are memorable then nobody
else has those are the stories that you
want to share with the industry because
they'll remember you that way okay so if
someone's envisioning their story and
how they may explain it first off how
will they or in what arena will they be
telling this story like when would it
ever come up to say hey you know what
Lee tell me about yourself I've seen
what you've written but I want to know
your deal in every general meeting an
executive will set you down and
literally say so tell me about yourself
just like that we talked earlier I was
doing a lot of interviews for this book
that I just written and in that
environment I'd gone into me with agents
managers executives I've never met with
before I can't tell you how many times
folks that I was interviewing would sit
down with me and say so Lee tell me
about yourself those are the moments
that it's assonance in every general
it's an every opportunity who are you is
there anything for us to connect on is
it the story that you tell is it the way
that you tell that story is it the
sensibility
with which you see the world so it's in
every general meaning every last general
meeting tell me about yourself other
than what else do you have
it's perhaps the most popular question
in this industry Lee where would someone
actually be telling their story and how
deep did they go how light do they keep
it can I envision the scenario as to how
someone's gonna be asking about me sure
oftentimes it's gonna happen in a
general meeting it niceties bottle of
water tell me about yourself can I get
you something to drink tell me about
yourself it's very blunt and upfront and
do your show you know I have writers who
have different versions of their stories
so I have one writer who suffered a
traumatic event in her childhood and if
she is meeting with somebody that she
feels an instant bond and Trust with
then she will go deeper she will go
darker with others she will leave the
nitty gritty out so you tailor your
story a little bit to see what in how
dark you want to go where but the rule
is never make it a therapy session never
bring in a story that you're not ready
to talk about openly without breaking
down without having a moment of Tears
all of that is unnecessary because a lot
of specifically in TV TV really looks at
what do you bring into the room right
it's not just what your writing is but
what personal experience what theme
speak to you what what do you bring with
you into the writers room so they want
to know that you're capable of talking
about whatever it is you're bringing
comfortably that it's not going to be a
therapy session that there's not going
to be suddenly an elephant in the room
that makes everybody uncomfortable so
you want to have those layers to the
story a comedy writers tend to really
look for the lighter fluffier happier
stuff or the really dark stuff told in a
very funny way you know tragedy via
comedy the drama writers tend to have
those more layered stories that they
choose how deeply to go into you know so
if it's being abandoned by your father
is it you know the life of petty crime
you're forced into a twelve and how cute
you were getting away with it
or was it
nice that you spent alone and when he
didn't have money to pay for electricity
and what that felt like and what it felt
like when social services showed up and
tried to upper you from your home those
are different ways to tell the same
story
so writers really do pick and choose and
it's important that you assess your
environment to really determine which
version of which story you're telling
ultimately it's always going to be the
same story because you're going to get
known for that story and then there'll
be other anecdotes that will come along
with it but it really is about finding
that core story and taking it out there
and getting the industry to know you
through it okay so different versions
yeah
maybe have an a B and C version you have
you know you have the kind of deep
version or you where you really kind of
drill into the story and then you have
your more for lack of better words
shallow version of it that is less
confrontational less demanding of the
listener or less uncomfortable
potentially it really is how you look at
it some some writers prefer to not
expose any sort of wound when they talk
about a personal story they're perfectly
happy to stay surface II and just a loo
to wound but it really is about planning
I mean rehearsing it and exploring it so
that when you go into a room that's not
when you're excavating your own story
and figuring out what's what works
you